الى مستجدات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
ونستهلها بدوي الانفجارات التي هزت
العاصمه الاوكرانيه
ان طائره روسيه من طراز ميكر 31 اطلقت
الصواريخ من نوع كنجال على العاصمه ماذا
فعل السلطات لتفعيل منظومات الدفاع الجوي
في كييف وعددا من مناطق البلاد من جهته
طالب عمده كييف بعد ذوي الانفجارات سكان
العاصمه بالبقاء في الملاجئ
علينا حاكم مقاطعه كورسك الروسيه
ان المضادات الارضيه اسقطت الطائرتين
مستجارتين اوكرانيتين كانتا تقتربان من
المقاطعه كما اوردت وكاله تاس تعليق جميع
الرحلات في مطار بون كوفو القريبه من
موسكو بسبب رصد طائره مسيئه هذا وقد اوردت
وكاله رويترز ان القوات الروسيه صدت عده
هجمات اوكرانيه واحرزت تقدما نحو مدينه
كوبيانسك الواقعه في خركيف من جهتها قالت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه استهدفت الاراضي الاوكرانيه خلال
الساعات الاربع والعشرين الماضيه بخمسه
صواريخ مجنحه ونفذت احدى وستين غاره جويه
70 مقذوفا من راجمات الصواريخ ما ادى الى
مقتل واصابه عدد من المدنيين والحاق اضرار
بمنشات مدنيه واخرى للبنيه التحتيه اشارت
الهيئه في بيان الى ان خطوط المواجهه بين
الطرفين شهدت 34 اشتباكا ونفذ الطيران
الاوكراني 12 غاره على مواقع القوات
الروسيه
نشرت قناه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه مقطع فيديو عبر
تيليجرام قالت انه يظهر لحظه استهداف
القوات الروسيه بصواريخ كورنيت تجمعا
للقوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه
شرق البلاد اظهرت الصور الملتقطه لحظه
اطلاق القوات الروسيه الصاروخه كورنيت
وتصاعد الدخان بعد الاصابه المباشره
للمكان الذي تتحصن فيه القوات الاوكرانيه